when my cat Bill died I was super bummed
cuz I really liked the cat and he died
at like 18 months and I remember being
sad about it I was like why am I sad I
feel like it's not fair that he lived
such a short life I was like okay so
that means that I had an expectation
that he would live longer than he did I
was like what if cats only lived 6
months and I got to danging out with
Bill for 18 months well then I'd be like
well I mean he lived a good long life I
mean I got him three times longer than
most people get their cats and so then
all of a sudden like my sadus was like
it shifted to like more of an
appreciation for the time that I had
with them it was simply just shifting my
expectation around what I expected